[Music]  this sculpture garden located in japan  was primarily unknown to the world until  2016 when a photographer stumbled upon  it  [Music]  there are around 800 sculptures in this  park depicting a mix of buddhist deities  and what are believed to be replicas of  real people  all were commissioned by a wealthy  japanese man named mutsuo furukawa  he is said to have paid 6 billion yen  around 60 million us dollars to create  this collection in  1989 there is a large statue of furukawa  which stands overlooking the park  [Music]  the people depicted are said to be his  friends and family but it is unclear if  they had any knowledge of their stony  replicas  they stand near a japanese village the  name of which translates to the village  where you can meet buddhist statues  although these lifelike statues stare  with blank expressions visitors say  there is an unsettling feeling to this  place and a concern that at night these  effigies aren't so still  you